[inaudible]
joining me today as a trial
lawyer focusing on civil,
criminal and constitutional law.
And according to his Twitter bio,
he's America's most successful
political gambler. Robert Barnes,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Having to be here.
I am glad to have you
here because you sir,
are smack Dab in the middle of a million
things that I'm thinking about all the
time. So I'm glad we're doing this.
Before we do anything related to civil,
criminal, constitutional, or any
other kind of law, political gambler,
what or what are we talking about there?
I know what we're talking about,
but tell the people.
Sure. I started doing when
I was real young, so the,
I used to bet friends and other people
with elections and then started doing,
it became sort of legal loosely in 2004
so I started betting on presidential
elections. I know sort of a side hobby
until the Trump election and Trump,
I thought this was a very
money making opportunity.
The British betting markets are now
much bigger than they ever used to be.
So I could bet as much money as
I possibly could. And, and, and,
and basically dug in much
deeper than I had before.
So I had sort of been around politics
but hadn't done in deep for maybe,
you know, 20 years or so. I
mean I had been very active,
but then it become inactive.
It'd become skeptical of the
political process and decided, well,
I should really dig in.
And as part of this,
I discovered this whole emerging movement
in a cross section of areas and what
was happening at geologically.
So I became involved for other political
and legal reasons along the way.
It was sort of like a Scott Adams when
big league kind of thing where you get
the, it's there somewhere
exactly, exactly.
Where you get like six degrees of
separation. You're trying to learn this.
He ended up learning four or five other
things in the process. And so I, you know,
I went to the Republican
National Convention,
the Democratic National Convention
traveled across the country,
talk to tons of people, dug into what
was happening in the social media space,
the reddit space, the Twitter space. I
didn't know what Twitter was until then.
Really. I knew some bird things.
A happier time. Exactly it was,
and maybe youtube was still youtube,
you know, it wasn't sensor too. So the,
I was uh, you know, involved and
invested in it, went over to the UK,
placed a lot of big bets. Uh, they
thought I was nuts when I was doing it.
They were like, you know how
Trump's not going to get elected.
That was the sort of consensus.
So much so that one of the big books,
Patty power actually was
paying out Hillary Clinton.
Beth's before the election.
So if you had been on Hillary
Clinton with Patty power,
they acted like you had already
won and paid you out. Are they,
are they still in business?
They are still in business. Uh,
though they took a huge hit on the
election after they'd taken a big hit on
Brexit,
which I'd been on before that.
And then after that had been
on various European elections.
So it was just understanding
how the electorate works.
I'm a sports better as well and being
able to predict and forecast elections was
fun and it was a way to
just make extra money.
And in the process ended up having this
whole life experience that was fun and
entertaining and very profitable.
Can I ask you what kind of profits?
We're talking
about half a million dollars. Yeah.
It's very nice. If I could admit that.
If I could a bet more, I
would've bet more. Yeah. He,
uh, there was the only limits.
As an American you only have access
to the individual betting shops.
You can't onto the Betfair and the
bet trade and markets. If I could,
I could have made seven figures,
but they use, it would have been
nice jeans. All right, well there's
a lot to talk about there, but,
but I really want to focus on some of
the legal stuff because we chatted a
little bit in the green room.
I'm starting to think as much as much.
I obviously am a free speech guy and
we're going to talk all about the first
amendment,
all sorts of things that the way the world
is going right now with the platforms
and with the trolls and with the
anonymous accounts and with the targeted
harassment and with the way that we
see media members attacking kids,
which you're very intimately involved
with and a whole bunch of other stuff.
I'm starting to think we really need
some legal answers to some of these
problems,
which is really against my default
position as a person in terms of speech.
And that's exactly why I wanted to have
you here. So before we get to all that,
um, just tell me a little
bit about your legal history.
When did you even get interested in law
and what sort of made you say, all right,
I'm going to be a lawyer.
Lawyers are that well liked.
Exactly. Well I, you know,
I've always liked underdog representation
and that sort of what my legal
practice is and that
goes back to I was a kid,
my favorite TV show is the equalizer.
It was always not realize the odds
and end to represent people against,
even if I'm representing someone
that's famous or well known,
they're stacked up against someone that
has more institutional power or wealth
or the u s government behind him.
And so I was a kid,
I like chose like Matlock and Perry
Mason and that was part of it.
And you'd see lawyers as being integral
to the process of making meaningful
change and particularly to stand up
for people who couldn't stand up for
themselves and use our legal
system and legal rights to,
to accomplish and
achieve those objectives.
And so that's why the law
always appealed to me.
It didn't appeal to me from a moneymaking
perspective though, had been very,
you know, had been lucky
in that regard. Uh,
it appealed to me and didn't appear
to appeal to me on a status basis.
It appealed to me is I can make
a difference for little people.
People like my father who spoke
out his whole life and there's a,
and often was punished
for it. And the, uh,
there's the old biblical proverb that
says the sins of the father will be
visited on the sun. I always say, well,
the sins against the father
or long remembered by the sun.
And so he was mistreated and maltreated
because he stood up, not for himself,
but for other people in a
wide range of environments.
And I just want it to equalize
the playing field if I could.
And was he a lawyer also now? He
wasn't. He was, he was an accountant,
but it wasn't a certified
public accountant. Uh, so the,
he went through all the craziness that
it was my first experience with the
credentialing society here. My father was
a very skilled and gifted account. It,
but because he wasn't a
certified public accountant,
he'd grown up in an era where
that wasn't necessary. Uh,
he couldn't get the kind of
jobs that other people could do.
And so he was often both overqualified
or underqualified for employment.
And then he had a habit of standing up
for people who are being maltreated or
mistreated in his work environment or
other environment, which led to him.
And he ended up being a newspaper.
We got delivery guy.
So when I was a little kid,
we used deliver newspapers,
throwing them outside the door. He, we
did a morning around and afternoon route,
uh,
and then he end up doing inventory work.
So he just picked up whatever
blue collar work he could.
So even though his education
and his intellectual
capabilities far exceeded what
he could get economically,
it was the product or a side effect
of their credentialing society and the
ability of more powerful people to take
advantage and misuse and abuse that
power against less powerful
people like himself. Wow.
So all right. So let's flash
forward a little bit to what,
what were maybe one or two of
the cases that kind of got you,
got you sort of on the map so that
now you've become one of the sort of,
I think one of the central legal
figures in the, the free speech battle.
So I started out doing all kinds of
free speech representation represented
victims of domestic violence was suing
big banks before anybody was doing big
banks. And subprime lending was a, I
had clerked for a native American tribe.
I'd clerked for a big corporate law firm.
I'd clerked for a street lawyer.
I always say,
if anybody wants to learn legal education,
just read all of John Grisham's books.
You'll get a good sense of outlet.
Legal practice really works.
Um,
and worked for a big high
profile plaintiff's lawyer
and finally got to a space
where I could do the kind
of cases I wanted to do.
And I liked first amendment cases and
it happened to parallel and two areas of
law. One was civil where I
was representing Ralph Nader.
He went on TV and said,
look, I'm getting bombarded. I
have no lawyers left to help me.
If somebody can please reach out. I
was like, sure, I'll take the case.
So there was, I remember we did the
case in Arizona was me, Ralph Nader,
and like 12 lawyers kept coming in. I
kept wondering when the door was gunshot,
we're not a lawyer came in another,
you had the Democratic Party Republican
Party both aligned to prevent his access
to the ballot,
deny people the right to
circulate petitions for the
cause or candidate of their
choice. And so I took that case and it
took four years, a lot of litigation,
a lot of fighting.
But ultimately we got one of the most
important precedents in the country out of
the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals.
It's now one of the most cited cases in
the country that protects the right to
circulate petitions, the right to
speak to the context of elections,
the right to choose who
you want on the ballot,
the right of third parties and independent
candidates to access the ballot.
In a weird way though, even though just
by the fact that it took four years,
isn't that part of the problem
right there? Cause yes,
four years later it's like he doesn't
necessarily have the energy to run again
or the movement kind of moves
on to something else, et cetera.
It was like the beginning of lawfare
of its own time, politically motivated,
ideological law,
fair to exclude independent and dissonant
voices from being able to meaningfully
participate in the political process.
And the main goal and objective
is to silence the audience,
to not allow the audience to hear or
choose or participate in the way they want
to choose.
They don't get to choose their news,
they don't get to choose their views.
That's what the censorship
campaigns were about.
And that crossed over into representing
people who are accused of being tax
protesters.
And these were people who had very
distinct political views about the way the
tax laws were operating. They were mostly
upfront about it with the IRS. I mean,
how many people you know,
write letters saying,
I'm not going to pay taxes
and here's what some of those,
mostly these were
libertarians, basically. Right.
It's never somebody that hates the tax
system because they want to be taxed more.
Right, exactly. That's never
happened. Precisely. Exactly.
And it's people being
open and honest about it.
They're not trying to cheat anybody.
And I tried to defraud anybody
in the US Supreme Court.
Has had 20 years ago in a case called
cheek versus the United States.
They were not supposed to put people
in prison for having different beliefs
about the tax laws,
especially if given this as a country
that was founded on people who had very
unique beliefs about the tax laws.
Uh,
so I ended up representing
Wesley Snipes in that context.
I'd also represented him previously when
he'd been falsely accused of, of uh,
of uh,
uh,
parenting a child in New York where they
were abusing the family court system to
invade his privacy, to
lie in liable him. Uh,
and basically t because of his celebrity
uses celebrity to make themselves
notorious. Uh, so we brought
a unique civil rights case
in that context. Had One,
got them to fold and capitulate.
He hired me then to represent him in the
criminal case on a whole bunch of tax
charges. Ended up acquitted
of all the felony fraud,
conspiracy charges and even
half the misdemeanor charge.
Um, on cases like that,
I'm always curious. Um,
when it's a high profiles rich
celebrity and it's tax related,
I always think it's like
these people moved me,
a guy like Wesleys night movie star,
you know,
he's worth millions and millions
of dollars. The idea that he would,
and I don't know the specifics,
so please correct me if I'm wrong,
but the idea that he would know every
specific thing that his accountant was
doing all the time.
It seems crazy to me.
Like he's running a business where he's
mostly probably focused on acting and
traveling and everything else and it's
like the idea that unless he instructed
the guy to do something illegal
that you'd end up in jail.
Because if something like that
seems pretty bananas to me
completely.
Because what had happened with him is
he'd had one accountant advisor that he
started to distrust.
I think this guy's up to something on,
on real estate deals and other deals.
It turned out he was completely right.
He was trying to tell the
New York authorities for
years before the guy ended up
getting busted and he had,
this guy was involved with Tom Brokaw.
He was representing a whole roster
of high profile celebrities.
Turned out he was embezzling
from them in mass.
He had abandoned his wife or
a stripper long story. So the,
this guy ended up going to jail for a
long time. But, but snipes was like, hey,
there's a problem here.
And nobody would listen.
And that led them to turn
to other professionals and
they said, you know what,
if you have any questions, we'll go right
to the government and get your answers.
And he was like,
well that's gotta be no problem.
They're going to talk to the government.
They'll figure out what it is.
That's how this unfolded. That's how this
whole thing unfolded. It was in fact,
they even tried to delete and destroy
all of his letters and correspondence and
communications. And luckily they
were, he had separately back them up.
If he hadn't,
we wouldn't have been able to prove how
much he had communicated directly to
them. He even asked to
be audited. He said,
come in and audit me and then come back
and tell me what is it io and why it is
I owe it.
And how does the legal system work?
And this is somewhat rooted in the
African American and native American
tradition who has a long history of the
law is not being applied the way they're
supposed to be on the books.
So the idea that maybe the law is not
being applied the way it's supposed to be
wasn't foreign to him.
You have native American tribes whose
tribal agreements are still not being
enforced.
You have African Americans between 18
and 65 and 1955 in the United States.
Like his parents, like his grandparents
who said the law on the books,
that they had the right to
participate in the political process,
the right to be on the jury,
the right to run for office.
And yet that wasn't happening in reality.
So the idea that there was some mismatch
here made sense to him and he just
wanted, he said, well, let's go right
to the government and I'm Wesley Snipes.
I have a little bit of a tension, they'll
probably answer my questions at least,
and then everything will get resolved.
That's why the jury was shocked by the
case. This was a very conservative jury.
The lead jury foreman was a guy who had
been a long time corrections officer and
upstate New York. They had deliberately
the jury pool they'd picked.
It was literally an all white jury pool.
So there was a joke that it was as, as,
uh, the only thing more white than the
snow fall from the Green Bay packer in New
York. Jazz came the day before was
the dairy pool in this nice case.
But now nine of the 12 jurors who are
honest and got onto the jury said they
didn't think he should be convicted,
do anything.
There were three jurors
who were holdouts who said,
we want to convict him of things.
And we came in with,
they admitted they came in with a bias
before they became part of the jury.
So on the misdemeanors, they did
a split verdict. They said, well,
will convict them on these
three misdemeanors even
though we don't think he's
guilty of him because
that will be no problem.
They didn't know there'd be a wacky
sentence because there was shock at the
outcome of the case.
Uh,
so how much of law is just that?
Just the public attention
stuff, manipulating the
media. I don't have to name,
I could probably name a zillion
lawyers that seem like they're far more
interested in fame for themselves.
Then doing the right thing
and just managing optics
rather than getting to just
what is right.
Precisely. That's what
it often is. I mean,
you're seeing it now in the Roger Stone
case where there's an obsession with
silence again and all the people on the
media on the left that talked about free
speech and talk about the ability to
protect yourself and how our criminal
justice system has problems or
suddenly muted when here it is.
You have a judge spending all this time
saying maybe we shouldn't allow him to
publish a book. How has that become part
of American criminal justice process?
So the effectively,
it often is defending a person in the
court of public opinion because often with
the government is doing is
using people as sin goats,
using people as sacrificial lambs,
using people to coerce public opinion,
often not really rooted
in the facts of the case,
not really rooted in the law of the
case targeting people solely because of
their celebrity or their fame.
Uh,
and then you have lawyers who often look
at a case and they don't look at the
case about how do I win the case.
They look at how do I get
the most press coverage,
how do I get the most media coverage?
And they often deserve their
clients in that context.
So it's critically important,
especially in high profile cases to
put the client first and to manage the,
the court of public
opinion at the same time.
Yeah. And that cannot be easy,
especially in a day of social media.
And look the fact you're here talking,
so it's not like you're, you're,
you're not like a totally private person.
No.
And yet you want to do what's
right by your clients and Yep.
Exactly. So like in snipes case, the,
I think the odds going back to high
was an eight to the odds that he was
convicted of the top felony fraud
counts was eight to one. So there was a,
they said there was only about a 10,
11% chance of him being acquitted.
You had see, you know, people on CNN
saying that he had no chance to win.
Some are still prominent legal
commentary. And now, uh, and
we always have legal common commentary,
people on CNN often,
but all the cable networks
who get everything wrong
and they keep bringing them
back.
It, it's like the political
commentary. What, Oh, for stress.
And there's the people that are mostly
never practice law. Never tried a case,
never dealt with a real days. And, and
it's amazing. They'll just, they're there,
they have a law degree,
but they often don't have
any legal experience and
they're really, they're from,
or for political purposes,
they know if they say the right thing
that they're media bosses want them to say
they'll get rewarded even if what they're
saying is complete and utter nonsense.
Yeah.
So one of the things that I've been
saying over the last couple of years and,
and you know I'm a free speech guy,
is that right now I'm more concerned
that we're silencing ourselves.
Then the government is coming for
our speech at this very moment.
Now of course I understand the government
can always come for our speech and
there are many ways that you're laying
out right there that they can through
going through the IRS or or whatever else.
But I'm more concerned right now
about sort of the mob mentality,
the way we're weaponizing the media
and social media and the rest of it.
So let's just start with the big
question right now. Social media,
are these publishers or platforms
right now, Twitter, Facebook, youtube,
and can you explain the
difference between them?
Absolutely.
So all of these big tech
platforms originally were
able to obtain their monopoly
status two ways. First, they got
Congress to pass special immunity laws,
uh,
loosely called section two 30.
The particular section of the law is
that applies that says we're going to
presume that everything you do is as
a platform and not as a publisher and
consequently you'll be immune
from any lawsuit as a publisher,
as long as you are acting as a platform.
So meaning that you're just the,
you're just the space so to speak.
People can put all kinds
of crap up on there.
You can decide what you take down or
leave up, but you're not endorsing it.
Exactly. You're just the public
venue. You're, you're the, the,
the venue where they're coming to organize
the Republican Party on the election
night, right? You're the restaurant,
you're the, you're the convention centers.
That's all you are.
And then that was even additionally
privately promised by people like jacket
Twitter who said, I'll be the free
speech wing of the free speech party.
So he induces people to participate,
induces people to become part of Twitter
and to give them an a competitive
economic edge against their
then competitors on the
grounds. And hey look, one,
the law only applies if we're a
platform, not a publisher. Secondly,
we are promising you we will protect
your free speech rights and your free
speech liberties.
Now it's important in that context.
Free speech means the right to
not be stopped for your speech,
the right not to be
harassed for your speech,
the right not to be censored
for your speech. It's both.
That's why I was telling for free speech
is not just the right of expression.
It means I have a rights that someone
can't target me because of my expression
and use elicit mechanisms.
They can question my ideas,
they can attack my ideas.
If I'm a public figure,
they have limited space in which
they can talk about me as a person,
but what they can't do
is invade my privacy.
What they can't do is
follow me down the street.
What they can't do is put a
billboard outside my home.
These are things they can't do.
So is that,
I mean,
to me that's a really fascinating change
on the way things have happened because
if I was to look at just generally
what's going on on Twitter these days,
if I was to walk down the street right
now and somebody just everyday was
waiting outside my house and started
screaming at me and all sorts of things,
there is legal recourse I could take,
right? I can file a, what can I do
[inaudible] a civil suit and get an
order of protection against like people.
Like I did a lot of work back in the day
when I was a young lawyer for victims
of domestic violence and
we were part of that,
the beginning of the orders of
protection that got instituted for them.
But it's not limited to the
domestic violence context.
It's anybody who stalking anybody who's
harassing anybody who's invading your
privacy.
You have an equitable right and a legal
right to bring legal action against them
and have the court say,
I'm going to stop you from doing
this and if you violate this,
you're going to be
responsible for legal fees.
You're going to be responsible for costs.
I can even put a statutory amount
on there and they have to do,
they'll say every time you violate this,
it's $1,000 or 5,000,
10,000 whatever's necessary to deter
those laws exist already there.
So are those laws,
are there any laws related to that that
exists in the digital space? Now, again,
I want to be very clean when we're
doing this because, so for example,
all day long trolls are jumping at
me. Go Fuck Yourself. Or you know,
just the word.
It's far worse than that usually.
But like just the worst kind of things
all day long. Same accounts, I block them,
I mute them. They just make new
accounts over and over and over. Okay.
It's not the worst thing in the world.
I'm still here. I'm alive. It's okay. Um,
but doing it in the digital realm,
I think people would see that very
differently than stocking someone just
outside of their house or
in the realm of reality.
It is only to a certain degree,
the same laws apply.
So it doesn't matter whether it's the
digital world or the physical world.
The same stalking laws apply.
The same harassing loan was apply.
So somebody who stocks can be sued,
somebody who stocks and they can even
be charged with crimes under particular
cases so they can be referred
for criminal prosecution.
That's happened to people that have done
that too. Mike Cernovich for example.
So the, uh, so you can use civil remedies,
you can request criminal
remedies with criminal referrals,
you can bring equitable actions,
you can bring legal actions and of
courts are actually very sensitive to it,
particularly like in California where
because of the problem of Stalker Razzi,
they expanded the,
through the kind of protection either in
the digital space or the personal space.
And the u s supreme court has increasingly
recognized that these days those
spaces are indistinguishable.
So it's interesting to me because
as part of the, let's say,
the free speech crew online right now,
I'm very hesitant of a lot of this stuff
because it's like I want everyone to be
able to express themselves.
And yet I understand we need
certain super specific laws,
libel laws, slander laws, harassment laws,
and yet there's a certain irony where
it's like the free speech crew are the
ones that are going to have
to defend those laws is like,
it's like a really weird place
for people like us to be in it.
I agree the way I think of it as
I see it as an unequal equation.
So what's happening is you're seeing
big media, big powerful forces,
people with big platforms be
able to defame little people.
It will be able to run smear
campaigns against people.
It will be able to attack and,
and encourage stalking and harassment and,
and online mobs at will and
not be held responsible.
And it's the little guy that's still
fighting for their free speech.
And yet they're the ones,
the little guy who's getting sued by big
institutional actors are backed by big
institutional players and they're
being sued for defamation.
They're being sued for liable, they're
being sued for there being the platform.
And so we need to do is equalize that
playing field because the first amendment
is also about protecting everybody.
Speech.
And that means the little guy can't get
harassed in ways the big guys immune
from and the big guy can't use powers that
the little guy doesn't have access to.
So it needs to be equalized out.
So true free speech means people who are
important in the independent press and
the freedom of press of the independent
press, not be harassed, not be,
not the legal system,
not be used against them,
disproportionately indiscriminately not
have the platforming happening against
them disproportionately indiscriminately.
And that's what's taking place.
And that's what needs to equalize.
So a true free speech means we need to
have some equality of treatment between
everybody.
Okay, so now backing that to the
platform versus publisher part of this.
So they help get these law,
what statute did you say to section
two third section two 30 okay. So they,
they help get these laws passed.
Now they're treated as platforms,
but it seems that they're
acting often more as publisher.
Right. They know, admit that. So in other
suits that I brought against Twitter,
they said that they are a publisher and
they want all of the protections as a
publisher.
They went all the legal privileges of
a publisher because the publisher has a
wide range of special protections,
particularly events has any
institutional former backing.
So there are certain libel laws that
apply to individuals differently than they
apply to corporations.
The same is true of big media publishers,
so they're now saying to courts,
so in the Prager suit against youtube,
youtube and Google's defense
is we're acting as a sensor,
we're acting as an editor,
we're acting as a publisher and look at
all these privileges we have as a, as,
as a publisher,
which a lot of people,
and it was one of the issues we raised
was if they're acting as a publisher,
they shouldn't have the
immunities of a platform.
Unfortunately the courts have interpreted
what congress said to them in a
political way, and this is often
the case with a lot of law,
a lot of laws that interpreted through
a political framework and how they
interpreted it as,
oh,
the Co is congress doesn't want
us to allow big tech to be sued.
So we're going to give them all the
protections as a publisher and all the
section two 30 immunities as a platform.
So they have a degree of protection.
As senator Holly described it,
a degree of immunity and benefits
that no publisher in the world has,
that Congress is the one that actually
gave it to them as the courts have
construed it though somewhat argue.
That's beyond what Congress intended.
Right, so Prager lost the initial lawsuit.
Correct. Are they, and I know Dennis,
but I actually don't know the answer.
Are they pursuing other illegal measures?
You're still trying to go
through the appellate process,
but they're unlikely to prevail under
the current environment because the
current environment is such that like the,
when I pursued Twitter,
I brought unique novel theories.
I brought breach of contract theories,
a consumer protection act theories cause
my equitable theories because my view
was Twitter had lied to people to induce
their participation profited from that
participation sold.
That person's like someone like Charles
Johnson would come in and 30,000 other
people joined Twitter to
follow Charles Johnson.
They now have all of
their private information.
They get to aggregate that information
and then marketize it and monetize it and
then they get to censor in band Charles
Johnson forever from Twitter because
they don't like one tweety mate.
Well,
if my view is that's really
a breach of contract,
that's really a breach of equitable
duties and obligations, but the court saw,
oh congress is saying section two 30
means I'm not supposed to allow Twitter to
ever be sued for anything.
That's what's happened and that's why
Congress needs to fix that side of the
equation because unfortunately the courts
haven't stepped up to do it themselves.
Do you think there is an interesting
piece of this that is just because of
anonymous accounts and I don't know
what the legal protections or non
protections would be around that,
but if you generally look at
what's happening online, if you,
if we removed anonymous accounts and
by the way, as a free speech guy,
I'm not for that because I understand
the off many times, many times.
I mean I see this with people
that I meet at live events.
They'll come up to me after and they say,
you know,
I have an anonymous account because
I'm a conservative and I, you know,
so it's not that they're trolls,
it's not that their flame flaming
people or whatever else it is.
But there's a piece of me that thinks,
man,
if you just removed
anonymous accounts and put,
put aside the decent human
part of it for a second, sure.
That actually 80 to 90% of all of this
nonsense would disappear because you've
got brave keyboard warriors with no skin
in the game that are trying to so havoc.
I don't know if there's a
legal piece of this somewhere.
There is a legal way to do it.
So if you're an operating on an anonymous
account and you're doing something
that's not protected by
the first amendment, like
stalking, like harassing, like,
like invading someone's privacy,
which is a broad toward,
that covers a wide range of remedies,
including like in the Covington pay case,
they'll bring the first
case that establishes that
doxing is in fact an invasion
of privacy. So, uh, you can sue, you
can require that Twitter or Google,
whoever did it, Facebook
identify that individual, uh,
and consequently that individual can be
held legally liable for their course of
conduct.
So people who think they can hide,
they can do bad things behind anonymity.
You're wrong,
they can do good things
behind it and enmity.
And the First Amendment encompasses
that anonymity is often critical to all
kinds of free speech.
But if what you're doing has always
been outside the scope of the first
amendment like stalking,
like harassing,
like intending to censor and chain
people based on lies and libels,
you can be held individually liable and
you're an anonymity of your account will
not protect you from legal responsibility.
It's so interesting because I'm hearing
you on all of this and then there is
this other,
this,
there's the absolute is part of me on
speech that even though I know we need
these protections more than ever,
there's just this little
piece of me that's like, ah,
I don't want everything to get
caught up in legal ease. And that,
and I guess that ultimately is the balance
that guys like you have to deal with
every day.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It was the pitch that we made to
senator Holly was don't treat these as
utilities and start to regulate them.
I understand why people are calling
for that because what they're seeing is
monopoly power. The interesting
thing is in the first amendment,
including in California, uh, and to,
it used to be the law and it
still is the law in some places,
which is if you have the effect of a
corporate monopoly on the public square,
you are then considered a state
actor for first amendment purposes.
This was established way back because
you had company towns who are like, well,
how do we suppress this union movement?
Well,
why don't we just own the whole town?
We only share if we own the copy on
the public square. Now we'll band.
Now we'll ban circulating. Now
we'll band organized. Okay.
By that definition, you would argue
the social media companies are
absolutely okay.
It's called the [inaudible] doctrine
here in the state of California,
which applies to private malls.
Private moles can't ban you
from circulating certain
things in the public spaces
of those private malls.
Well,
is there any more monopolized public
square than big tech media than Twitter?
Then Facebook, then youtube
and Google, they own,
they own 85 to 95% of the public square
and all corporations are creations of
the state and they get certain
protections for that because they have a
corporate charter.
They're given certain immunities from
individual liability for participating in
that company. Well, in exchange for that,
once they get to the place where
they monopolize the public square,
those two things exist,
both of monopoly and the public square,
which is usually over 75 80% control
of a market space. When they have that,
and when it's the public square,
I think they should be held to the same
first amendment standards as everyone
else because otherwise we create this
huge loophole in the first amendment to
privatized control of the public square.
So, uh, Eric Weinstein, who I'm
guessing you're familiar with,
I had a couple of discussions with him
about this and one of the ideas that he's
put forward, and my libertarian
side doesn't really like this but,
but I see some value in it
is that because we don't,
we don't have public spaces
online. Correct. So it makes
everything, so in effect,
everything's private.
There's nothing public.
So the government has
nothing to do with anything.
But maybe this would be an actual good
use of the government if there were
platforms that were government platforms
that the only rule basically was,
you can't break the laws of the United
States so that people could get their
information out there, but you, but if
you break the laws of the United States,
you're in trouble.
Then the private companies
could do whatever the hell
they wanted and we'd have
no reason to. We'd have no ability
to stop them. But in effect,
because everything is private,
there's nothing public anymore.
Right, exactly. And so my view is
that once you become a monopoly,
and particularly when you become a
monopoly based on federal congressional
immunity, then you have different
obligations than any other private actor.
So that's one argument. One argument is
if you become, if you become a month,
if you choose to have a monopoly in the,
in the public square space,
you're going to have the same first
amendment rules as any government actors.
That's one option.
Another option is just to condition their
continued immunity on First Amendment
inclusion. Those are the arguments
that I've made to the Twitter lawyers.
In the Johnson case it was like, look,
you guys don't have to reinvent the wheel.
Like well they said they were worried
about stalking and harassing and it was
like very simple. Just take all the
first amendment rules that already exist,
incorporate them within your
terms of service and then you'll,
you'll eliminate 90% of
your concerns and questions
and you won't have to deal with
a lot of the nonsense, right?
Like right now their rules would be
considered void for vagueness if they were
staying here because you have rules
that are subject to individual women
discretion
and they're intentionally
written that way. Right.
So did you catch any of Tim Pool and uh,
uh,
Joe Rogan with Jack?
Exactly. Yeah. I mean he detailed this
instance after instance after instance.
I mean the way they decided to replatform
Alex Jones was highly subjective,
very interpretive. And I've
seen far worse, I mean for
example, the Covington case,
you had a prominent Hollywood figure show,
an image of saying the saying the
Covington kids should have to go through a
shredder and be killed. You had as lawn
calling from the be punched in the face.
Nothing was done about that. And yet, uh,
Alex Jones posts something that's
just a funny video and they're like,
oh my goodness, we have to
get rid of Alex Jones. Okay.
So I want to spend a whole
bunch of time on cuddling him.
Cause I think actually that was the
moment that this shifted and maybe at a
legal sense it crystallized
in my mind a little bit more.
That's actually when I reached out to you.
Sure. Cause I saw you just going for a,
going for it. And I thought, okay, this
is a conversation we ever had. But let's,
let's talk about John's for a
minute. So Jones, so you've,
you've done some defense work with Jones
representing Alex Jones and info wars
and now his outside general
counsel on all these legal matters.
So you represent him across the
board on all of these things.
So I guess my first question is what's
it like when Alex Jones knocks on your
door or calls you up? Yeah, he's a very
animated guy. Very nice guy. Very Open,
very sincere.
What was fascinating is from the get go,
he was saying 90% of what they're
saying about me isn't, isn't the case.
He's like, I would defend us on for on
free speech and free press grounds anyway.
But what they're actually saying,
I said,
I didn't say I never
attack these families.
I never went after these family never
told people to go to the families' homes,
none of that. So this is that stuff
specifically is about the Sandy Hook,
Sandy Hook case. And so that
they're either, they took a,
a media matters video and assume that's
what I said and it wasn't really,
they took most of that out of context and
didn't put in that I had corrected the
record long time ago. Um, and so part
of it was, you know, very nice guy,
actually very friendly guy,
very accessible guy. Uh,
even more so than snipes.
He gets mobbed when he goes out in public
with people hunting selfies and that
sort of thing.
Um,
and he doesn't act like the Jaguar did
with a lady very nice and sociable and
friendly. Um, so the runs that, you know,
nice small business enterprise access
TV to talk radio to Internet and he's
intended to be the poster boy of
their d platforming campaigns. They,
they at when I told the press is this
case really isn't about Alex Jones.
It's about the ability of the
independent press to operate. Uh,
we'll law fair be discriminately are
desperately used against ordinary
individuals in the same
way that d platforming is
happening already in the big
tech space. And so are we going to protect
the little guy or not? And Alex Jones,
they figured would be the convenience.
They would sort of
create a parody of them,
a caricature of them that they could
get the public to believe, make them,
make the audience feel bad if they
watch him the a May feel guilty to be
associated or attached with them.
And as soon as my representation
was announced and another lawyer,
norm Pattis big old school civil
rights lawyer in Connecticut,
I think he still has a pony tail.
I mean he's old school.
He had friends and family members that
are connected to what happened at Sandy
Hook. So he, uh, immediately, you know,
wanting to be involved in the case.
As soon as he was Huffington
post writes a hit piece on,
they don't talk about a civil rights
legacy. They don't talk about any of that.
It's tired.
The whole thing is intended to smear him
and to sending a message that if you're
a lawyer and you dare to fend Alex Jones,
we're going to try to destroy your
reputation in the public space.
And that's exactly the problem that
needs to be fixed and remedied.
So related to Jones specifically,
I mean one of the things that I thought
was was most incredible, I forget
the exact order of it, but basically
within 48 hours all the platforms,
so came down. Yes. And
it's like, okay, is that,
is that that you guys truly your calling
each other and coordinating it or is it
that you're all sort of cowards,
you somebody breaks the ice and now you're
just followers and I don't know that
it matters either way. Right? It
probably doesn't matter either way,
but what I thought was okay,
it doesn't even matter what he has
said short of breaking in American law,
in my opinion,
the real issue here is that
if he can't be on there,
then
why is Farah can on there? I'm not
even, I'm not making a comp comparison.
Direct comparison to them. Why is Hamas
on there? We could do a zillion other
things. You know, parity
is obvious and evident.
There are people who have said far
worse things that just happen to have a
different ideological
intellectual perspective.
Even if you took all the accusations
against him at face value in 90% of them
are not true. The what and that's
your typical smear campaign.
The conservative or the person
on the right or the person,
some on the independent antiwar left
will often be attacked and smeared.
90% of what's said about them is not true,
but even if it was true,
what the other side has said is usually
far worse and far more egregious and far
more excessive. And it's the obvious
disparate treatment they're using their,
they're concentrated power to uh,
any including their law fair power to
effectively wipe out the little guy so
that only the big guys
voices heard and don't me.
It's about the audience because
Alex Jones is still going to talk.
It's just candy audience here.
So it's about their right to choose their
right to choose what news they want to
look at, what views they want to have,
what, how they filter information.
I always say like,
like I don't represent people that are
accused of racism or the rest people that
are actual races. Not everybody
these days, everybody,
well being accused and being an actuary,
but people who are
really involved in some,
like I generally avoid
representation of them. Um, the uh,
because I just don't want to be affiliated
it because that is an old personal
issue. But if you look at what
those people, I've always said,
let those people debate because if you
watch Richard Spencer debate somebody
else, 99% of the time, the Nice, calm,
reasonable person is not going
to say Richard Spencer was right.
So always expose ideas to more ideas,
more sunshine because let the ideas get,
let trust the audience.
That's really what they're all saying.
All what big tech is doing,
what these big lawsuits are doing against
the little guys is intended to say we
don't trust the audience
to make up their own mind.
We don't trust the audience to
make up their own decisions.
We have to control what you think.
We have to control what you do because
you might choose something that we don't
want you to do. If you actually have
freedom of choice, freedom of thought,
freedom of expression.
Do you think lawsuits are the
answer to stop some of this stuff?
I'm also realizing right now that our
runway to fix this is becoming perilously
short. Like we're getting to
the abyss pretty damn quick.
The 2020 election is right around the
corner and that seems to me to be what
this is all ramping up to.
Absolutely. The Covington case was
such a glaring example of that.
So I was on vacation in Mexico and so
let's just go all in on Covington right
now.
Yeah,
so it was a little town north of port
of are out there was just hanging out,
just you know,
going through Twitter and I had four son
of a bitch try on Twitter, on vacation.
Exactly does that. Let's see what
happens. And so I see Maggie Habermann,
the premiere reporter for the premiere
news publication in the country covering
American politics. New
York Times. Yeah, exactly.
Basically calling for the expulsion of
a bunch of kids that she's never met,
that she doesn't know based
on an event she didn't see.
And I found that so shocking. I was like,
we're crossing a whole new line now.
If we're going to go, it's one thing to
go after what somebody said 10 years ago.
That's problematic on its own terms.
We'll get to that in a little bit too.
Exactly. That's what we have
statutes of limitations for,
but the a is that you're not going to be
held responsible for what she did when
you're Tan, but the, or when you're
20, when you're 40. But the here,
these kids were who were just going up
to DC to be part of the pro life march.
Uh, and usually the pro life march at five
at family participate in that. They're,
they're just having fun.
You know, they're not mean.
They're not out there harassing people.
They're just expressing what they
believe. A, these kids are having fun.
Probably the first time ever to Washington
DC there by the Lincoln memorial was
beautiful memorial and all of a sudden
they start getting harassed out of the
blue and they have likely never met
the black Hebrew Israelites, right?
Some of us that have
no hoods coming every,
I lived in New York City for many years
by these guys. Many times. Every insult,
known demand. It's like really?
They're almost like an insult comic.
If the routine is so extreme,
it's like they find something going next
to the next thing the next day or like
bad don Rickles all. Exactly,
exactly the worst version, right?
It's all you combined Farah
Khan with Don Rowe, right? So,
but these kids have no ideas and they
have an African American friend that's
there with them and the he's being
attacked and so they start defending him.
They started attacking, making various
anti gay slurs there. They question,
they respond back to that in defense
of people who are gay. So I was like,
these are in that mean kids.
These are kids trying to
handle a shocking environment.
They decided to go internal and start,
okay, let's not deal with these guys.
Let's do our school tears. One of their
school cheers as the old Haiku is a,
as the Haiku dance, which is the Great
New Zealand rugby team, all black eye,
in fact, two weeks before it's shown
it to my son, because I was like,
look at how awesome. It's awesome.
It's all over youtube by the way.
Anyone can watch it.
And absolutely. It's a,
when I first saw it in the
movie with Matt Damon, Yeah.
That's the greatest sports dance I've
ever seen. So the, in fact before,
if I want to get inspired by something,
I'll just put it on and go get ready.
Yeah. So the, so they
do that as part of it.
That's why when the kid's tearing his
clothes off and it's right after that,
it's happening,
then all of a sudden the native American
comes up with some friends and he's
doing the drums. So two
thirds of the kids think, oh,
he's joining in because we just did
the Iq thing. Oh, this is great.
And what do they know?
The most popular, uh,
native American sports thing they know
is the, is the Tomahawk Chop from, uh,
from the Florida state, from Kansas
City chiefs and Glendean Atlanta Braves,
all the places where they're familiar
and there, you know, right on the,
on the border of the Kentucky,
Ohio border.
So the kind of programs they'd be
familiar with, that's what they see.
Not Nobody's mocking him, nobody's
chanting, build the wall out of.
Nobody's blocking him, nobody's
surrounding him. And then
at one point they start,
some of the kids start to figure
out, okay, something's odd.
Because some of the people behind
him are saying, go back to Europe.
And it's like, Whoa, where
did that come from? Uh,
and then they realize something's
weird and then they just leave.
And then as they're on their bus home,
all of a sudden their lives are being
upended and they're not being upended by
just some random body counts.
Who started their being offended by
Kathy Griffin who calling for them to be
doxed. They're offended by Maggie
Haberman calling for them to be expelled.
They're ended by Matthew Dowd,
who's on ABC,
who is a prominent Catholic on ABC saying
that things need to happen to these
kids. And in Navarro saying bad
things need to happen to these kids,
almost the entire media is,
and then you have Hollywood celebrities
calling for them to be put through the
shredder for them to be
attacked for them to be,
you had a writer who claimed to
be part of Saturday night live,
say she's going to extend sexual favors
for anybody who physically assaulted
these people. And I was like,
these are probably the kids.
These are, by the way, these are
blue checked verified people.
These are all of them.
Give the people the Twitter says
you should pay attention to that.
We've verified that. We validated that.
We've authenticated that we've authorized.
And uh, in Twitter, social media does
almost nothing about this. In fact,
they run with the fake news story and
these kids lives are almost over in five
seconds based on a misleading
video. Um, and so I saw it and I,
when I first saw the video, I was like,
oh, that's going to be fake news story.
Just cause you know, DC politics, you
know, you know lefty protest culture,
you know,
the chances that a bunch of Catholic
kids came up and found a lefty to harass
isn't that real high and Washington DC
and say that happened in a small town in
Alabama. Okay, maybe uh, but then I was
like, this story doesn't make sense.
And so I was like, okay,
that will probably blow over.
And that was well as getting on
a plane to go to boost areas.
Then I get to the and see
these things and I'm like,
they're going to destroy
these kids' lives.
And I realize if they
think if they can do this,
they can do anything to anyone at anytime,
anywhere.
And that's exactly.
So then you started tweeting about it
alongside a couple of other people and I
thought a couple of other people in the
legal world and I thought, all right,
I've got to talk to this guy because if,
if this one doesn't get corrected,
which fortunately thanks to you and it's
ongoing, you and several other people,
it is getting corrected. But I thought
if this one doesn't get corrected,
if we let them demolish high
school students, we're done.
We are done.
So can you catch us up on sort of where,
where this is all at [inaudible]
now. So what I did initially is I first
just put out a tweet and said if anybody
wants to sue Maggie Haberman
now represent it for free.
And I was just agitated
and it was just ticked off.
And I didn't tune into Twitter until
like two days later when I came back and
all of a sudden it blown up and I'm
getting all these inquiries and I'm like,
okay. I realized that this was
becoming very high profile.
And so I go on Fox and my goal is to
get everybody to start to retract,
start to back up, start to retell the
different story. And unfortunately,
almost all the institutional
media starts to backtrack fast.
So to be clear, you did not want
to go the legal route. Actually,
you are giving everybody, man, I saw you
do this. You gave them the chance guys,
just delete the tweets.
Did you even ask them to issue apologies.
I don't even know.
Well that's about all I said was I said
that has got 48 hours to do one of three
things.
Either correct or delete or apologize.
Just do something to correct the
record and let me to her credit,
Congresswoman Omar,
who he,
he has no problem saying anything
under God's green earth. Uh, she did,
she did it within an hour,
but she only did it because
roll call covered my story.
So his role called covered my story.
He's like, oh, maybe I can get sued.
And W you know, took it down. By the way,
right before that she had sent out a tweet
linking them to white supremacist and
a whole bunch of others.
That whole bunch of false information.
She labeled them in a whole new,
unique ways.
They'll leave it to her to figure
out a way to do that. The, uh,
this is a member of Congress,
but thinking of Senator Warren is
running for the presidency of the United
States,
repeating false statements about these
kids because she's native Americans. Yeah.
Yes, yes, exactly. She has to
stand up for her truck. The level,
like they portrayed him as a
native American elder. Well,
I clerked for native American tribes. I
worked for one of these old school lefty,
one of the best trial lawyers in the
country, and I was like, hey. I was like,
I don't think he's an elder
of that particular tribe.
Then I realized they were just confusing
the terms because he's elderly.
They were going to call him an elder.
I was like,
that's an insult to all the most native
American elders are very carefully
selected. They take their job very
seriously. In fact, their court system,
if we had an ideal court
system in the world,
it would be the native
American elder system.
I'd be all for it because there's 12,
12 people sit around and you come and you
tell them your dispute and they try to
find a remedy that will satisfy everybody
and they try not to be too punitive.
They try not to be too uh, too
involved. They just try to say, okay,
what's caused this problem? How can
we address the cause of it? And,
and they're focused on reconciliation.
How can we bring people together
so it doesn't happen again?
And people don't feel bad at the end
of it. Not Great for your profession,
but exactly that much better system.
I'd be all for it.
I mean I'm happy happily for fifth,
my law degree to see
that system put in place.
Have the 12 members of your community
get to decide these kinds of disputes and
find ways to put people back together
and protect all the things that matter to
us rather than deepening the division
and the bitterness that exists.
And the legal system often creates that.
People often leave it even when they
win unsatisfied. And so the uh, so,
but so they put this guy in that context,
there's like,
he wasn't a Vietnam war veteran.
The was really not really being accurate.
They're trying to script a narrative,
trying to tell a story,
but doing it to these kids and include
the message was if we can destroy them,
we can destroy you.
It was an ultimate exemplar mechanism
of media narrative structure and that's
why I volunteer to help them out. And so
now represent 14 families in Covington.
Oh, about 90% of the people I went
on Fox and said 48 hours notice,
just clean it up and we'll be done.
And even after that,
I've given people additional opportunities
and additional opportunities.
Please take it down. Please correct that
none of the family members want to sue.
They don't want to deal with the
nightmares of the legal system.
They don't have to go through
all that hassle hurdle. Um,
but they want the record corrected and
they don't want to happen to anyone else.
That's it. And so I was like, let's
set a record. Let's set a pattern.
Let's set a precedent year that this
can get corrected and remedy that.
You can't do this to these kids.
You can't do this to these people
that you do have standards.
You have to be bound by those standards.
You have to be governed by those
standards and you have to act according to
those standards. For those that
refuse to do anything about it,
they're going to be sued.
So some of them still left the tweets
up or didn't apologize. Kathy Griffin,
Matthew Dowd, oddly enough, Maggie
Haberman, uh, Senator Warren, uh,
congresswoman Holland,
uh,
those are the five highest profile
examples of people who refuse to correct.
When you see a mob descent,
it's a little,
it's a little hard to figure
out how coordinated it is,
whether it's group thing.
Is this coming from the top?
Is this organic as much as you've
had to deal with these things,
and especially since you dealt with the
most recent one that's still unfolding
right now, what's your take? Is it,
is it a little bit of everything?
It's two different things.
One is there,
they've started to greenlight mob culture.
That's what it was scary here because
this started out with a bot account who
was spreading it through sort of liberal
ideological culture who is trying to
create an online model.
But the reality is that online mob
would have never reached critical mass,
at least as it related to these kids
without the blue check mark crowd saying,
Yay, Yay, Yay. And
that's the problem there.
The green light for online mob behavior
and that's why they have to be stopped
and they have to correct their actions
or they have to be remedied in court
because they are the ones
that are permitting it and
expanding it. And for them,
I don't know how often it's deliberate
and how often to cultural mindset,
I used to call it cotton ball culture.
So in the south,
people used to go to the cotton ball.
They're part of the privileged classes
when they're 16 and 17 and they're sort
of in co incorporated and
acculturated to a certain mindset.
So it's not that they all
get together and conspire,
but that they have a certain
point of view that's,
that's been created by
the sh culture they share.
And I think there's some of them online
mob culture that's been festering over
the past half decade,
decade.
And the worst part of it is that continued
to be green light by institutional
people or people with big
platforms and big power.
Are you shocked also how the racial
element has become so blatant?
So it was like these kids are white so
they have punchable faces or excusing the
black Israelites to quizzes
because they're black.
So they can call these kids
faggots and that's okay.
Even though you're supposed
to defend gay people.
But I guess if it's black people,
you know they create this oppression
Olympics intersectional too. Yeah.
This intersection alluded. See,
so are you just shocked how,
how solidified that is in
so many people's brains
for like two different reasons. One,
whenever I see people do it or raise it,
my instinctual view is I was like,
well what does that person
actually done for civil rights?
So like when I've been attacked him like,
well,
I've done civil rights for 20 years,
I've done very difficult cases in very
difficult places advocating for civil
rights.
So I was like,
is this person really out there trying
to help protect people or is it somebody
who wants to,
uh,
social brownie point and social prestige
point for being on the right political
side? Um, and that's 95% of it.
These are people that aren't actually
doing anything to improve the wellbeing of
African Americans and
Latinos in this country.
The second part of it is it's
become social prestige to,
uh, out people that are up that ever
particular disfavored political class.
And it happens to be there right now or
disfavored favorite political classes
are white or men are people of
certain sort of parts of the country,
certain political orientation kids
in mega hats. Exactly. I was like,
that's the same sort of bigotry.
The bigotry doesn't know
color bigotry as bigotry.
And this has just racial bigotry disguised
as a, as tried to protect people.
They're not out to protect
people throughout the hurt
and harm people and they
just want to feel morally
justified when they do it.
So when you now have to have to move
forward on this lawsuit that you're,
you're saying you're going into
not really cause you want to,
you're giving these
people a chance to go out.
How does this even work logistically
when you're going after people that have
nothing to do with each other other than
they all did it on the same platform.
So we're going to bring in as a class
claim so all the plaintiffs will be
combined.
So all 14 kids will be one group of
plaintiffs and all the defendants will be
combined.
So the uh,
so you can combine the defendants
together when there's a common nucleus of
facts and they're are
behaving in a coordinated way,
even if it doesn't rise to the level of,
say,
illegal conspiracy or aiding and abetting,
which it may in some of these instances,
the effect of it is you can add them
together because for judicial economy
purposes,
they're all part of the same event and
it's easier for one judge to preside over
all the cases combined. Then the case is
differently. Uh, and so it's interesting.
Some of the left media client use use
of these kinds of defamation claims has
done used this exact procedure and it's
time to use the exact procedure back the
other way.
You gotta be careful what you wish for.
Exactly.
So let's talk a little bit about what's
going on with Tucker Carlson right now.
Now Tucker has been on this show.
I go on his show every couple of weeks.
I find them to be a decent guy.
We have political disagreements that we
have expressed to each other publicly
before,
but I think he's on the right side,
especially when it comes to the free
speech stuff. Now media matters,
which you mentioned already there,
they're going after him.
They're finding an old audio clips on
a shock jock, a Bubba, what's his name?
Bubba. Bubba Gump. Bubba Bubba.
Is there any, I know it's got bubble
and the bubble. That's something. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Whatever it is.
In effect. Howard Stern,
like figure exactly where I was thinking.
I tweeted something the other day that
I wish Howard stern was maybe a little
more engaged these days. Ndas.
I don't begrudge him. He's,
he's lived through a lot and he's had to,
he's been a great fighter on our
side of the free speech thing,
but it's like if he was to take the 30
years of stuff that politicians, actors,
Comedians, authors, musicians,
everybody has said the crazy sexual
acts that had been done in that.
So you all those things and said, you
know what, this is all part of life,
right? All say things we
get in atmospheres where you
joke differently this way,
then you would that way,
all of these things,
I would love to help have him
aiding us right now in this fight.
So that's just one piece of this.
But putting that aside,
media matters is now digging into old
things of, of Tucker's. And you know,
apparently he said Faggot.
There were a couple of other things and
they're trying to make it sound like
he's racist and he's for abusing
kids and all of these things.
And I wonder what his legal
recourses now he's not apologizing.
That's one thing which I think
that's pretty good for the,
if you're going to stand against the
mob, don't apologize, but also if there,
because their goal is
just to destroy this man.
Their goal is in some sort
of legal justice, right?
Their goal is their goal
isn't to help anyone, right.
Unless there's doing something
that I can't figure out.
Their goal is to destroy a man
and if you could destroy a man,
you can destroy an idea and you can get
all sorts of other people to shut up so
nicely.
What the hell do we do?
It's very much a censorship shaming
campaign designed to marginalize his
audience and marginalize him from having
access to his audience and to be an
example to future people
so that they won't, Hey,
you better not come after big tech,
which is really what distinguishes Tucker
from anyone else on Fox or anyone else
in the political conservative space.
He's probably the lead high profile
person taking on big tech in this country.
One of the leading guys saying,
I think you're telling me I should have
you on retainer. Is that where exactly?
Well, I mean that's what's happening.
It's a systematic, it's institutional.
It's in,
it's deliberate and it's obvious,
so like I first got it familiar with
this aspect of it in the context of
representing Alex Jones because I was
trying to figure out why do people think
he said a bunch of stuff that he
actually didn't say or did things that he
actually didn't do or think 90% of what
he said was this as opposed to that and
then found out watching Joe Rogan that
it was actually a media matters thing
that Joe Rogan himself
walked. He's like, oh no.
I saw this media matters thing was like,
who would trust media matters?
It's like they, they're politically
motivated, they're partisan oriented.
They take various forms of like people
complain about secret corporate cash and
dark money. Immediate matters has tons
of secret corporate cash and dark.
Is that, is that a big problem right here
that the nonprofits now are probably,
I don't know all the laws
related to nonprofits,
but they're probably in almost every
political case stepping beyond their
boundaries?
Did they?
Definitely are,
and then what's happening is they're
becoming clearly their partisan
organizations. So here you have, nobody
would think media matters is nonpartisan.
I'm pretty sure they didn't go after
joy reed on cable news with her whole
thing went down about the anti gay blog
posts.
Exactly.
They've defended all kinds of people on
the left who said all far worse things
and at least our politically ideologically
aligned with the left are supposed to
be in the first instance and this
is the left set of standards.
That's something you say 20 years ago
somehow means you can never have a public
platform ever again for the
rest of your human existence.
This is not an American standard.
This is not a conservative standard.
This has very much a left standard.
The,
but they don't apply it to their
own people ever at all. I mean,
some of the things Joe Biden
has said over the years, yeah,
he's the leading Democratic
candidate for the presidency.
And then that guy opened
his mouth and crazy stuff.
Okay,
well half the things that Trump says now,
although he says them sloppily are the
exact same things that Obama said about
immigration and Clinton
said about immigration and
Dianne Feinstein in the rest
of them.
So the, it's extraordinary for the, for
this sort of one side of application,
but clearly Tucker is a target because
Tucker is willing to take on big tech and
the goal is they're testing. When can
we use something in the person's past?
What's extraordinary about all of this?
What unites all of it,
whether it's the Covington case or the
Alex Jones case is that you have people
who are unwilling to debate ideas.
It's all about if you disagree with them
then they're going to target you as an
individual. They're going to make
your life difficult as an individual.
They're going to harass you as an
individual stock. You as an individual.
You've already been to
Tucker's house by the way.
Precisely when his wife was there and
had no clue what was going on and they're
banging on the door.
And that was a reason why Fox went off
Twitter for an extended time period.
Cause Twitter would do
nothing about it. I mean, the,
the extraordinary
discrepancy in disparity,
everybody can witness and everybody and
people like Tim pools on the left can
say this is problematic.
This is kind of obvious what you guys are
doing and recognize how problematic it
is because they're not going to
stop there. It's like Alex Jones,
they're not going to stop with Alex Jones.
They're going to use it as an example to
try to go after everyone else to scare
and intimidate everyone else. You
better not be in the independent press.
You'd better not be in
the independent speech.
You better not be sharing a dissonant
narrative or we're going to be able to
demonetize you d platform
you debate you, uh, or,
or defame you routinely and
regularly and get away with.
And that's why we need equalize the
playing field. And, but for Tucker's case,
what he could do,
uh,
is he could potentially go after
media matters for misrepresenting.
You're mischaracterizing
the set of events.
They have a habit of putting out a video
that decontextualizes what happened.
They did it to Alex Jones.
They would take them where he's talking
about this subject put into a minute, uh,
where it looks like he's talking
about Sandy Hook. Exactly not,
he's talking about something else.
And they would say,
these are all the statements. So my,
they've likely done the same thing to him,
but there's limited remedies.
I also saw one of, I think it was one
of the directors of media matters.
I actually retweeted it saying,
if you think this is bad,
we've got a lot more or something
to that effect. And I thought this,
they're telling you how evil they are
because they're saying we are releasing
this information in a calculated way
to destroy a man. We're not just,
we're not just doing it for public good.
Like we found all this stuff and we're
just going to put it all out there on day
one because people should
know about his path.
It's like we're going to keep the monster
being fed so that it can keep feeding
on
correct and it's why are they so scared
of ideas? If they think Tucker's wrong,
an ideas debate his ideas,
why attack him?
Why especially why the tech him on
something he said 20 years ago on a shock
jock show.
There's also something crazy you could do.
You could actually pick up the remote.
You're not going to believe this.
There's a button on that thing that
allows you to scroll up or down.
Have you seen this thing?
Exactly. I mean if you don't
like what you're hearing,
you don't have to listen to it. If you
think it's wrong, you should engage in.
Years ago, Professor Lash, great historian
passed away some years ago. He said,
the reason why we expose our ideas and
debate other people isn't necessarily to
persuade them.
It's because they're going to expose
ideas that there are weaknesses in our own
argument. And we often research a
topic when somebody says like, oh,
that must be wrong.
We go and find out about it would become
more informed by engaging in the public
debate process. And that's,
that's good, that's healthy.
But these are people who fundamentally
don't believe in free thought,
free expression and free speech.
Fundamentally,
they believe that you should
have the right thought,
not that you should have free thought,
you should have the right expression,
not that you should have free expression.
They have combined sort of
the inquisitional Catholic
church with like 1920s
communists and they've integrated
the two in their approach.
And they're using our legal system and
using our political system and their
superior power in the cultural,
uh, areas of influence,
whether it's Hollywood,
whether it's big media,
whether it's big tech to suppress and
oppress those people who have different or
dissonant views than them, including
people on parts of the left. So,
I mean people like temple is being called
a Nazi because he appears on Joe Rogan
and ask a few questions at Twitter.
I mean this is insanity.
So, uh, that's actually, I was
going to go somewhere else,
but let's jump there for a second.
So like for example,
when I had Tim pool on last week,
there were verified people on Twitter
calling Tim a Nazi and Mia Fascist or me
and Nazi and Tim, a fascist. I, I've
mentioned this before. I've had ah,
how I grew up around Holocaust survivors.
I lost family on both my mom
and my dad's side. Now again,
I'm the free speech guy,
so I don't want to sue these people.
But is there some legal remedy for this
if I was someone different than I am?
Correct. Yeah, there
is. Because for example,
I took a couple of years ago
the Cassandra Fairbank's case,
he gets him a role and one of the I,
one of the reasons I
took it is I want Sandra
former lefty, by the way, she's
now all Trump, but former lefty.
I had drinks with her one night. She gave
me her full on lefty, lefty, lefty, lefty.
Yeah, exactly. Part Puerto Rican. Yeah.
And she was accused by Emma Roller,
a flashing, a white power gesture.
And this was the universal,
some others became a white
power. And I was like, what?
So and so she was on Twitter and
he's like, I've got to stop this.
Can somebody help me? And I said, I'll,
I'll help for free because I liked the
area of the case and thought needed to
stop this because they're used to being
able to say, I'll call someone a Nazi,
I'll call someone a racist.
And that's not actionable at law.
And I wanted to change that.
I wanted to say when you make very
specific statements about someone's belief
structure that someone can interpret in
a jury can objectively verify as either
true or false that I think that
should be something you can sue over.
So I brought the case in DC and we
couldn't meet the actual malice standard,
but the court said yes, saying someone
is a racist and a particular way,
like saying it's a white power gesture,
you can be sued for the United States
for liable in lies and under the
defamation laws of DC, which are more
restrictive than a lot of other laws.
So that's established the standards.
It always,
people think I can just say
anything and never get sued.
That's what we're going to make the point
in the Covington case, no you can't.
If you say things that you know not to
be true that a jury can look at and say,
I can objectively verify this.
We the juries make determinations about
whether someone is involved in a hate
crime every day.
They made determinations whether someone
has racially discriminatory animus or
motivation every day.
So if they're good,
if someone's accusing
you of being a racist,
that should be actionable in law because
a jury can make that determination as a
matter of objective fact,
and the Fairbank's case establishes
precedent that you can under certain
circumstances get legal remedy for that.
It will never cease to amaze me that
the free speech crew or the people that
have to do certain things through law
exact such just to maintain free speech,
which aside,
it sounds so counter intuitive,
but it's so fascinating to be so a
couple of times you've mentioned Fox,
I think there's something
interesting happening here. Now,
has CNN or Msnbc ever put you on? No.
Have they ever asked you to come on?
CNN did way back about two years
ago. Okay. So CNN did two years ago.
MSNBC has not,
Fox puts you on right now.
Fox only puts me on and they put me
on with, no, I'd go on live shows.
They don't tell me to say anything.
I can say whatever the hell I want.
I often bring up liberal Craig while
I'm, while I'm on there. Yep. Uh,
but it seems also clear to me that partly
what's going on with the Tucker thing
is that they are really going for
Fox there. The plan is, all right,
we'll take out Tucker.
He's sort of the bravest or the
most outspoken or whatever it is.
But really then we'll make this about
going for foxes licensing and broadcast
abilities and, and everything else. You're
nodding. So I suspect you agree with me,
but I,
I'm amazed because it's like there's so
much left he media and you never saw the
right trying to destroy
all the left immediate.
There's basically one fox and it doesn't
mean I love everything they're doing.
I don't, but you need some
counterbalance Dell. Yeah, absolutely.
If you have the approach of
the inquisitional Catholic
Church or institutional
communism of a status variety,
then what?
What drives you crazy as the heresy?
So you don't look at it and say, Geez,
how many fair balanced expressions do we
have on both sides to the acquisitional
Catholic Church?
There's only the Catholic church
perspective and everybody else needs to be
burned at the stake for the
status Communist. Same dynamic.
There's one state channel,
there's no alternative state channel,
there's no anti-state channel. So when
you come at it from that perspective,
what unite, say Alex Jones,
the Covington case and Fox is,
these are three institutions and they
represent different institutions that are
giving an independent narrative.
So when I was at Yale,
we did a history project that was actually
about why African Americans and poor
whites in the south,
we're often treated or,
or portrayed and very discriminatory
ways and cultural medium between 1900 to
1970 and what you find is historically
those communities have alternative
narratives.
There are grandparents and parents tell
stories different than say the civics
book version they learn in
third grade in public school.
And so consequently those groups are often
changed and censored and portrayed in
a negative light so that the broader
public audience wouldn't trust them to
listen to them or react to them.
So the same thing as here.
Like you look at the Covington kids,
they represent private Catholic education.
What is private?
Catholic?
Catholic education is one of the last
institutions of independent thought
compared to say all the public state
schools and public institutions.
So it drives him crazy that they
represent this institution that they can't
control their thoughts in mind of right,
because they don't have access to that.
Right.
And then you even saw in the midst
of all this, I'm sure you saw this,
there was that guy from the New York Times
who said, I want to know your stories.
Remember, I forget what the Hashtag you
used was, but he wanted to know your,
you're Catholic.
It was like Hashtag Catholic schools
stories precisely because let's now New
York Times, let's go after them
once we're done with this thing.
So let's go around.
Do the whole Catholic church,
let's go after the Catholic
schools because we need
people to be afraid to be a
part of those schools, to be ashamed.
If they're connected to those schools,
parents worry that if their
skills are listed on their kid CV,
their kids' futures will be impaired
and not have these schools being
independent sources of thought outside
of the sort of cultural liberal, uh, uh,
hegemonic view.
And the same thing is true.
Like Alex Jones represents sort of an
independent part of the press of Fox News
represents an institutional part
of the press that's independent,
that expresses its own perspective. That's
not part of the left majority. I mean,
CNN and Msnbc and ABC and NBC and CBS,
even when they're using public airwaves
are overwhelmingly on one side.
Same with PBS,
same with NPR,
and there's a lot of good value and I
watch all of them at different times or
listened to them at different times,
but I want the other side
expressed and so why?
It's this fear of free expression,
this fear of free speech that's
leading to the censorship campaigns,
a shame campaigns, these
targeting campaigns, these
privacy invasion campaigns.
When I've told people is if you're ever
to the point where you're attacking a
person or trying to shame a person trying
to censor a person trying to invade
their privacy,
then what you're really looking,
you're doing as you're looking in
the mirror and telling yourself,
I've failed on the argument.
I can't persuade on ideas.
No audience would
actually believe my ideas.
So it's an admission of failure and
they're really resorting to these extreme
tactics because they're recognizing
they're losing in the public debate.
Do you think part of it also is
that it's intentional? Not now,
perhaps they're losing in the public
debate. I think that's probably,
you could debate that either way.
On one hand I'm very enthused about
sort of where we're at in this.
On the other hand it's very scary
too because you see this socialist,
whatever the hell that is the
horizon. So, but putting that aside,
do you think part of it is that they're
in doing it intentionally because they
just want to basically uh,
so chaos all over the place.
That partly what they need for
whatever their political goals are,
they need this system that has been
pretty freaking spectacular for 200 plus
years to appear chaotic. So they, so
they, what do they do? They soak chaos.
It's very,
what's amazing is how paralleled is
the 19 20th street violence in Europe.
So you see like a lot of the communist
tactics that were used back then and the
fascist tactics that were used back
then was in WWE were designed to sow
distrust in the system. So distrusted
the institutions. That's it protected.
That's it every day.
Now Aoc doing another thing about how
evil we are in Reagan's evenly capitalism
capitalism to hate that.
I think with like the combination you're
talking about where there's these bad
ideas that are spreading and yet
winning in the public debate,
what unites them is if
both sides get presented,
most people will take a
humanitarian decision,
will make a good choice based on their
common experience and their comments sets.
Whereas,
and so that's why this side that wants
to spread their ideas knows they can't
allow that open fair debate to happen
or those institutions to be trusted in
protected and it goes back to it.
If they can d uh,
if they can get people to
no longer to not listen,
to not hear independent voices,
to be afraid to be a part
of independent institutions,
to feel ashamed if they're connected
to it, to say, Hey, if I'm a lawyer,
I represent this person, I'm going to
be attacked. If I'm, if I'm in the,
in the public arena and I
voiced an independent view,
I'm going to be targeted and harassed
and stalked and then the rest,
they want people to be
scared and intimidated to
express their ideas because I
think they know that in an in a
non chaotic open debate structure,
they don't win.
And I think that's what the wrecking,
because otherwise you don't have to
resort to these ridiculous tactics and
techniques.
If your ideas are great and popular.
You don't have to use chaotic
techniques. You don't have to, uh,
you don't have to try to censor people.
You don't have to attack people.
You don't have to say when it Tucker say
20 years ago on a, on a shock jock show,
you can say,
Hey,
I disagree with what he said yesterday
on Fox and I'm willing to debate them.
And Tucker is one of the
few people who says, Hey,
you can come on the show and we'll debate
quite literally what his statement said.
Exactly. If you don't like my ideas, let,
let's talk about exactly.
All right.
So I want to ask you something that
I think will sort of thread, oh,
you know what,
I want to ask you one other little tech
thing and then something that I think
that will kind of bring us full circle
here. So one of the things is, you know,
you see me do this all the time
where I have to publicly shame, uh,
youtube in Thai,
they're monetizing my video or making
sure people aren't being unsubscribed to
the rest of it. And then in a certain
amount of people will say, but Dave,
you're a libertarian or whatever,
you're not allowed to complain because
you don't want the government involved,
which is so idiotic because of course
I'm using my voice as a citizen.
That's what you're supposed to
do. Okay. Putting that aside, um,
do you think there is some interesting
legal mechanism if it was to be found out
that they were treating
traffic differently?
So that's a little bit different
than what we talked about earlier,
was talking about content specifically.
So you're saying this or that,
but what if they're actually
turning the screws just based on a,
not something you said,
but they have a general sort of a broad
sense that they don't want certain ideas
getting out there.
I think there are contractual principals,
equitable principles and consumer
protection principles that are in play.
So once you induce someone to participate
in your platform and then you monetize
their participation, to me, you
have contractual obligations,
equitable obligations you can't have
on just enrichment. So you say, Hey,
if you participate we,
these are the rules and if as
long as you abide by those rules,
we will make sure you share
in the profits for example,
of monetizing your individual video.
And if they don't do that,
if they manipulate the algorithm,
they misrepresent facts,
they induce conduct and then only keep
the profit for themselves or use it for a
politicized purpose.
That's different than what they said.
Those are all consumer
protection violations,
equitable law violations and legal
violations sometimes recommend a remedy by
statutes,
sometimes remedy by common law,
or there's no reason for
big tech to be above the law
right there. There might also be some
legal thing related to their own board,
right? I mean, if they're doing
things that are not related,
if they're not doing the most
profitable thing, they're bored me.
I don't know exactly what it was.
Yeah.
All of the shareholders can take action.
So there could be a derivative suits by
shareholders. They could go to the board,
but they could also bring derivative legal
claims against the institution saying
they're not promoting the best profit.
They're creating undue
legal risk and liability.
They're not behaving in a
matter consistent with their
professional obligations
and their contractual obligations
to their, their own investors.
And so they can also bring action.
And in fact, the left I went,
I told a lot of people is look at what
the left has done between the seventies
in 2000 you'll see a lot of legal roadmaps
for how to go at what they're doing
now. So they were with some
of the, you know, the, uh,
on the apartheid
campaigns in South Africa,
they targeted different
people using shareholder suits
using shareholder claims,
using shareholder complaints to remedy
that of people who are profiting from the
apartheid system in South Africa.
Why can't we do the same thing now
based on the same legal theories,
same factual predicates as the,
as what's taking place here,
which is inconsistent with their
obligations and promises to people.
I guess partly in, this brings
me to the, to the last question,
it's partly about bravery.
You need citizens who were brave enough.
You need lawyers who are brave enough
and they've created a system where
everyone is afraid.
Because the,
when I go out speaking to college
campuses or even I do Q and, a,
when I'm doing standup or wherever I go,
the question I get more than anything
else is I'm afraid to say what I think and
what should I do.
And it's usually students that are saying
I want to get a grade cause I want to
get out, I want to get to Grad school or
whatever. And I always think it's like,
man, if everyone's thinking
this, if we all just stopped,
if we all just stopped acquiescing to it,
we could actually change this thing
like that. So my question to you is you,
and you mentioned your father before,
but why, why are you willing to do this?
Why are you willing to
put your ass on the line?
Where does this come from in you?
So it's two things. One, it's, it's
growing up. So grew up poor in the south,
got a scholarship to private school,
scholarship to Yale. When I was at Yale,
they tried to get rid of
poor students who were there,
let it protest by leaving Yale in order
to get them to reinstate their policies.
And I saw there, I was like,
I'm one kid, I'm 19 years old.
I'm challenging all of Yale University,
which wasn't exactly a small institution.
And just by leaving the school and
getting public attention for it,
I got them to reverse their
policies and protect poor students.
Same access that I had to,
uh,
rights to full financial aid rights to
be treated in a nondiscriminatory manner
in the application process.
So as a, at a young age,
I learned one person can change the world.
When I was a real little kid,
I loved Medgar Evers and Medgar Evers
had this great quote where they asked him
why it wasn't afraid to die.
And he said,
most men die a thousand deaths every day.
I'm only going to die once.
And I was little kid. I was like, I
want to be at Medgar Evers. It's like,
that is so powerful. That is so
important. That's so influential.
And you realize one person
can make a difference.
And when you realize one
person can make a difference,
if they know it here and act on it here,
then you realize that,
that that's the power.
That's the passion.
That's what leads you to want to
change the world, not be afraid of.
I've had rogue agents threatened me,
a IRS,
people put me under audit every
other year whenever I want a case.
I've had a rogue judges threatened me.
I've had people say that they're going
to try and put me on a bogus criminal
investigation.
I've had every smear campaign known to
man had bomb threats coming because of my
Covington case representation.
And none of it concerns me because if
you understand that you really have the
power one person to make a
real difference in the world,
then other people will start to recognize
that and they'll act on their power.
They'll voice their,
their abilities,
they'll use their capabilities
to make a meaningful difference.
And that's how the world changes.
And that's how the world becomes a better
place. That is how you ended interview.
Can we smoke one of those cigars
he brought here, right. We're done
here. Follow Robert. I have a
feeling you'll be back here. Yeah.
I have a feeling it's going to happen,
uh, on Twitter at Barnes underscore law.